je fais souvent le même rêve jeu sans
soleil qui réchauffe ma peau et des bras
réconfortants qu'une serre fort et je
voudrais rester comme ça
de ma vie
mais ça pourra jamais se réaliser je
souffre d'une grave allergie au soleil
les rendez vous chez le médecin font
partie de mon quotidien il n'y a aucune
chances de rémission et chaque année les
risques pour sa santé augmentent donc je
passe mes journées à l'intérieur
derrière des fenêtres spécialement conçu
je dors le jour et je vis la nuit et
joue de la musique dès que j'en ai la
chance
ouais ça lui qu'est ce que j'aurais pu
dire salut je m'appelle katie price tu
regarde passer devant ma fenêtre depuis
dix ans je suis amoureuse de toi et
gestion des moindres mouvements bas
c'est ce que fait que je suis elle est
hyper maladroite avec les gars et elle
en fait des chansons géniales
c'est bizarre qu'on se soit jamais
croisés je passe devant chez toi tous
les jours pour aller m'entraîner
est ce à dire est qu'on fasse quelque
chose bientôt je suis super occupé toute
la journée mais je suis libre le soir
qu'est-ce que katie price a envie de
faire il ya tellement de choses que j'ai
envie de faire tu m'emmènes à ton
premier conseil du jour c'était une des
plus belles soirées
[Musique]
si bien de beignets
ça
ça me met mal à l'aise qu'ils soient pas
au courant je vais le lui dire c'est
juste que ça me fait du bien pour une
fois dans ma vie d'être autre chose
qu'une maladie
c'est trop grave pour que tu décides de
pam en parler vraiment désolé on n'est
pas le genre du couple a baissé les bras
[Musique]
m
c'est tellement vacher
[Musique]
m
qui réveille ça toute ma vie